how to get endorsements for your company
if you're just starting up and you have
a new product or new service a great way
to help establish credibility and get
the word out there is to get people who
are well-known to endorse your product
but how do you get in front of them how
do you get on their radar it's a
question that came in from one of my
readers Lana who has an educational
product and wrote this huge long email
but basically wants to figure out how do
I get people to endorse my educational
product so I've got three strategies for
you that I've used two different degrees
that hopefully can help you with your
business the first is involve them in
the creation the more people feel like
they're a part of something the more
likely they're gonna promote it so
here's a quick example of what I've done
recently I created a line of famous
entrepreneur trading cards I love
baseball cards growing up I was a big
fan of collecting baseball cards and I
had those my first business really was
like buying and selling training
baseball cards you know as you get older
you kind of want to relive your youth
not that I'm that old but I love I don't
know so I was thinking finally my
baseball card trading days and thought I
want to make my own line of baseball
cards how cool would that be but instead
make it for entrepreneurs and what I did
was I wrote to some of the top bloggers
who were in the entrepreneur circle so
guys like Gary Vaynerchuk Seth Godin Guy
Kawasaki those kind of guys and I told
them about my project and I wanted them
to pick who was gonna be on the front so
Seth Godin pigs Duncan Hines and Guy
Kawasaki picks Steve Jobs and so we put
them on the cart so we have I have my
Steve Jobs card it's you know all great
information motivational stuff about
Steve Jobs and on the back there's a
little picture of Guy Kawasaki and why
he loves Steve Jobs
so I'm involving him in the product and
created this line and once I launched I
just had the right to all the bloggers
and give them the card sorry I just you
know direct mail sent them the actual
physical card and most of them wrote
about it because they were part of it
they were happy with it they took
pictures with it and so involving them
in the process helped make sure that
they would promote it when it was
finished so I don't this awake and do
that with your educational game or not
the second is more product placement and
that's reaching out to people who would
find it interesting and offering a free
sample or a free demo and a lot of
bloggers a lot of people in the media
too are sharing the stuff that they like
and use whether they're getting paid for
it whether they bought the product
whether it was given for free or not and
the most successful ones are the ones
who do it with authenticity so I'll turn
down promoting things if I don't use it
or I don't like it I only hopefully
share the stuff that you know you guys
will find interesting because I find it
interesting and I'll do videos of me you
know using my new Roomba or buying new
you know bottle openers I do that
because I use those and I like them I
want to share that with you I get
pitched a lot by companies who want me
to do two videos for them do reviews for
them and I only take on the ones that
actually like so here's an example I've
got I'm reading this book now okay King
years it's a great book is by Taylor
branch so put that in a little closer
and it what it's about it's Martin
Luther King so I'm all about movement
now the suffer meetings about how to
build movement because I want to build
an entrepreneurship movement and
everything I'm consuming is around
movement so this book is really
interesting for me I love it I'm I'm
tearing through it I've got let me open
this up let me show you okay I open this
up so he signed it so this is great to
have them call my club with best wishes
Taylor branch and as I flip through it
get to the start that is a preface okay
I've got like I'm highlighting I've got
notes in the margin I'm taking notes on
everything that that feel like I'm
loving this book right and so this is
great and I'm gonna talk about it and I
talked about it in this video I'm
tweeting about it and
and at the same time I turned down most
of the books that get pitched to me
because just I'm not feeling that
connection to it so what I encourage you
to do is really take your time to find
people who have a strong connection
somehow with your mission with your
product and would be a good candidate to
actually use it those people would be
really happy if you've written a book on
creating the movement I want to hear
about it send it to me I want to read it
and if I like it you might be in my next
video okay that's how it works and most
people are pretty accessible email
Twitter Facebook YouTube you can find
people but do your homework to really
find the right people because the busier
they are the bigger they are the more
they're bombarded with this stuff like I
get this stuff all the time with people
wanted me to do reviews for them and I'm
really selective because I have a
limited amount of time so hone your
pitch really well the third thing you
can do and this is if you're really
committed to it if you stand for
something with your business then you
can help create your own movement around
that right so I don't know what it is
about your educational toys what you
believe for a child's education like
maybe the school system is broken and
kids need to learn by doing and you know
I don't know what it is like what do you
believe what does your company stand for
you can start to create content
educational content that you can involve
these bloggers in powerful content that
they will want to help be a part of
because they believe in the same thing
so now it's not just about selling a toy
it's something much bigger right and and
I believe that you have that in you it's
do you want to do the work because
getting all these guys on board they
will if they really believe that you
stand strongly for this cause if I'm
pitching my guides if I'm pitching my
trading cards whatever it is it's not
just pitching that it's much bigger I
can create a community around
entrepreneurship because everything I do
boozes entrepreneurship and the people
who come
your customers your bloggers the media
all those people are coming because of
the movement you're creating and they'll
end up buying your product because
that's a part of it why do people buy my
guides okay
so I launched the guides that called
zuga why do people buy the guard's it's
not because I'm I'm hard selling them
right you won't see a video of me saying
and you really need to go buy my guide
now and it's like 30% off last minute
sale go buy buy buy buy buy that's not
I'm not ramming it down your throat
because that's not attractive and that's
not what I stand for
but people end up buying them because
they're coming to me for entrepreneur
information motivation wisdom guidance
and this is just the next step of that
so it can be the same thing with your
product if you create a community and a
movement around what your company stands
for people will naturally want to know
what's next and will buy your product
and all your other products if that
helps now I can go on and on and on
about creative movements I learned a lot
from Martin Luther King and a few others
thank you Taylor branch of the book
anyway a few ideas on how to get your
promo products out there and it's it can
be really powerful because if the right
person endorses your product and sends
it out to their audience they could help
put you on the map so it's definitely
worth checking out believe for those
you're watching liked the video please
give it a thumbs up below subscribe if
you want to see more videos like this
and leave a comment let me know what you
think let me know leave something below
to let me know that you are human and
you like watching these videos and if
you have a question you can leave it
below too
thank you so much and I'll see you soon